[Musik]
das ist q&d zum Selbstversuch haarlos
als Frau und zahlreich möchte ich sagen
dass es mich mega gefreut hat dass so
viel positive Kommentare sind so viel
positive Rückmeldungen
das hätte mich auch sehr berührt dass
zum Teil geschrieben
hat oder ich bin jetzt sensibilisiert
auf das oder sich bedankt haben dass man
über das Thema Berichte vor allem halt
auch andere betroffene Frauen und an
einer Reaktion hat ganz besonders freuen
kann
[Gelächter]
was meint ja cool cool ja ganz viel
geschrieben hey Reaktion von dem Vater
ist super oder
geil
und muss sagen dass ich mega froh bin
das Umfeld habe wo so locker reagiert
hat und ja sie hat natürlich mir auch
extrem cool von auf dem Markt ist
geschrieben sehr genialer Reportage ich
hatte auch mal eine selbst Erfahrung mit
Glatze mir war das viel zu kalt am Kopf
die teils auch nachts beim Schlafen sehr
störende Kälte ist eigentlich der Grund
warum ich nicht mehr millimeterschnitt
haben möchte wie geht es dir mit der
Kälte am Kopf Tags nachts bei Wind
starke Sonneneinstrahlung liebe Grüße
das ist am Anfang es großes Problem sie
sag jetzt mal so ich habe wirklich immer
halt klar also auch zum Teil dinnert hat
oder so
beim Schlafen
das ist natürlich auch noch ein Grund
aber ich kann auch gemerkt dass man mega
muss aufpassen mit der Sonne also das
haben die vorher schon gewusst aber
jetzt was ein paar Tage
extrem am Kopf und man muss sich auch
nicht vorhandenen eigentlich kein
Problem ist in der Kommentar hätte es
auch Frauen
betroffen sind wo ihre Geschichte teilt
ihre Erfahrungen
es gibt vielen Dank für diese tollen
Reportage wie großartig und mutig dieser
offene Umgang mit dem Thema Haarausfall
da ich selber davon betroffen bin und
auch eben meine Haare wieder zum
nächsten Mal verloren habe und nun Karl
rasiert bin freut es mich umso mehr dass
darüber so öffentlich berichtet wird
gerne würde ich mich auch mit
betroffenen Frauen austauschen laut Elif
hat genetisch bedingte horusfall sie
schreibt als es mir das erste mal
aufgefallen ist habe ich mir große
Sorgen gemacht ich bin zu zwei
verschiedenen Hautärzten habe mich aber
bei beiden nicht verstanden gefühlt sie
meinten beide nur dass ich nun eben
diesen Haarausfall hätte und es nicht
mehr besser würde die Aussage hat mich
darauf
zum Beispiel in den erfahren aber nicht
unterwegs dass sie sich nicht
denn das natürlich halt auch noch viel
schlimmer macht für Sie
Betroffene Victoria beschreibt nur es
anders Problem was sie hat mit
und dem abrasieren vor allem sie
schreibt abrasiert hatte ich mir die
Haare auch schon des öfteren bis zur
Glatze ich selbst finde mich schön und
dann auch mal weniger schön und manchmal
mag ich mich gar nicht leiden vor allem
wenn ich Single bin denke ich mir es
liegt mit daran weil Frauen mit vollem
Haar einfach dem Idealbild entsprechen
bei der Männerwelt kommt meine Erfahrung
nach nicht so doll darüber ohne Haar
ihre Kompaktheit fragt warum hast du
nicht bei 6 mm angefangen sondern gleich
mit zwei Millimeter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
boah klar
irgendwie mit 0,5 oder 0,8 mm und bis
auf rasierte
2 mm da kann ich immer noch weiter aber
wenn torbe mir sobald ich länger sind
sieht man auch besser und ich kürze dass
sie sind
desto weniger gefällt noch und darum
kann ich sie auch ganz ganz kurz
meistens es hätte auch kritische
Kommentare der exklusiv 01 schreibt man
ohne Haare ist etwas Alltägliches so
ganz im Stil kein Problem stinknormal na
dann danke fürs women's playing Corina
ich fand es gar nicht lustig als ich
meine Haare bei mir noch vermiete 20
quasi verabschiedet haben ich habe
gesagt dass es für Männer nicht schlimm
ist oder genauso schlimm ist wie für
Frauen das will ich auch überhaupt
nichts oder das Minimieren ich kann
nämlich auch
so von meiner gehört wo seid dann genau
gleiche Gedanken und die genau gleiche
Zwiebel kann wie du auch damals wenn ich
mir Tor abrasiert
und das finde ich auch absolut
verständlich und nachvollziehbar was
halt natürlich aber ganz anders ist ist
wie sie der Gesellschaft angeguckt wird
ein Mann mit Glatze ist wirklich halt
einfach als normales Bild mit
öfter wie Frauen ist halt wirklich so
dass die meisten kaschieren zu stecken
und mich darum halt auch weniger gesehen
und genau das ist schon eigentlich Gange
es hat auch viel Kommentar geht zum
Thema Haartransplantation Perücke und so
weiter der Guru schrieb Respekt an die
Frauen dass sie so offen über das reden
aber wieso kein Haartransplantation
machen wo ja nur acht bis zehn Stunden
Resultat bringt ich als Mann hast
gemacht und frag mich wieso ich das
nicht schon früher gemacht habe falls
erfroren
das H schreibt dank der
Haartransplantation habe ich meine volle
Mähne zurückgekriegt das funktioniert
bei Frauen noch besser ja das ist
natürlich ermöglichkeit das zu machen
für mich persönlich fühlt sich das jetzt
nicht richtig an ich kann man jetzt die
Haare abrasiert zum das quasi
akzeptieren zum damit leben und man muss
sagen natürlicher Transplantation
garantiert nicht dass es noch einmal
wieder die volle Haare braucht hätte
oder oder dass man sich dann besser
fühlt der Abteil schreibt ich frage
wieso sie nicht einfach schöne
professionellekt ich finde einfach so
ganz kurze Millimeter Frisuren passen
viel besser zueinander als zu Frauen ja
das ist mir klar dass das nicht schön
finde dass man nicht schön finde
berücksichtigen
eigentlich nur vorstellen aber je mehr
ich mich an Dir ganz kurzer Haar gewöhnt
hat es zu das eigentlich wieder gerückt
und im Moment könnte man überhaupt nicht
vorstellen weil ich hatte irgendwie das
Gefühl ich hatte das so offen zeigt ich
stand jetzt zusammen und mit der
Perücken würde das wieder wie verstecken
dass die missgefühle ich glaube dass
Perücken
Kommentar vor der Verena zum Thema
hopfform und wer denn so einen Bastard
vertragen sie schreibt ja jetzt weiß ich
viel mehr doch was wenn man echt nicht
die schöne Kopfform für eine 1 mm Frisur
hat passt echt nicht jeder Frau mit
diesem Video geht es mir eher schlechter
gegen Frog wer entscheidet denn was
schönes Kopfform ist wer entscheidet
denn ob sich jetzt Frau das haben machen
sie attraktiv ist und das quadratge und
genau in dem Stil ist auch die Kommentar
vor der joland dass sie schreibt ich bin
29 Jahre alt und trage eine
Kurzhaarfrisur es ist praktisch und
gefällt mehr ich höre immer wieder dass
ich mutig sei und dass ich es ja tragen
könnte das macht mich jedes mal wütend
wer entscheidet eigentlich wer das
Tragen kann als dürfte man das als Frau
nur wenn man hübsch genug ist ja und ich
danke das trifft der Nagel auf den Kopf
zum Abschluss möchte ich keinen
Kommentar vorlassen von der Angelika sie
schreibt danke wie empfinden uns
vollhaarige als normal dabei ist den
meisten nicht klar dass unter mehr oder
weniger schick frisierten Haaren und
geschminkten Gesichtern die
Volkskrankheit Scham liegt die meisten
von uns gucken morgens in den Spiegel um
zu kontrollieren ob sie gut genug
gesellschaftskompatibel und so weiter
Aussehen jeder Schritt aus dieser
Normalität aus welchem Grund auch immer
bedeutet für mich ein Wachstum des
Bewusstseins in mehr wirkliche innere
Freiheit wir haben mit denen und
passende Wort möchtest
dann abonniert doch der Kanal
[Musik]